hasta el momento hemos estado trabajando
con ruido perlín en una dimensión pero
recuerda el problema que queremos
resolver está en dos dimensiones
afortunadamente podemos aplicar
exactamente la misma idea en dos de esta
parte es muy divertida recordemos para
generar variación en una dimensión
usamos una curva 2 de definiendo la
variación del color base a lo largo de
la línea usamos la componente x de la
curva para definir la posición
horizontal del pixel y la componente ye
para definir el brillo de cada pixel
pero para crear ruido en dos dimensiones
necesitamos una superficie 3d para
definir la variación a través del plano
piensa en una superficie 3d como una
colección de puntos que tienen una
componente x y y ceta por ejemplo esta
es una superficie definida por un montón
de puntos aleatorios piensa en las
coordenadas xy allá de cada punto como
la posición de cada pixel en el plano 2d
y la coordenada zeta va a definir el
brillo de cada pixel si hacemos eso
obtenemos un plano 2d que se ve así
observa que los picos de estas
superficies
tienen puntos más claros y los valles
son más oscuros como antes el plano
resultante tiene fronteras muy marcadas
entre las áreas claras y las oscuras eso
es porque su superficie no es suave
afortunadamente podemos subdividir esta
superficie de la misma forma en que
suavizamos la curva 2 de agregamos más
puntos intermedios a la superficie
obteniendo transiciones más suaves y eso
nos da esta variación de aspecto natural
que es exactamente el tipo de patrón
nuboso identificado en el paquete de
acabado probablemente quieres intentarlo
así es que en el próximo ejercicio
puedes emparejar patrones 2d utilizando
esta técnica te daremos un patrón y
podrás construir uno igual ajustando uno
el color base 2 la resolución eso es que
tanto nos acercamos o alejamos de
nuestra superficie y 3 la subdivisión
que tanto suavizamos la curva en este
ejemplo estamos manipulando sólo unos
cuantos parámetros pero en un proyecto
de acabados para una producción real
cuantos parámetros ajustas bueno los
personajes del fondo tienen generalmente
centenas de parámetros pero personajes
principales como arlo tienen
aproximadamente 2000